he's standing down as an MP he is
triggering an immediate by-election in
his constituency of Uxbridge and South
ruislip so the former prime minister
Boris Johnson will no longer be an MP
and this is in response to what he sees
as as a stitch up by the Privileges
committee
um what they we understand from his
statement is that they would be
recommending based on the investigation
that they did into Boris Johnson and if
you remember he appeared in front of
that committee to answer their questions
they were looking at whether he broke
the ministerial code in terms of what he
said in Parliament he was very
disparaging if you remember at the time
about that committee he says in a
statement that they will be recommending
that he should be suspended for more
than 10 days now the process of that
would have been that they would have put
that to Parliament MPS would have had to
vote on it it could they then would have
would have had to go to voters in his
constituency so it would have been a
long drawn out process but they could
eventually uh have that could have ended
in a by-election in his constituents in
his constituency he has triggered it
himself he has stood down and this is
the key bit of his statement I have
today written to my Association in
Oxbridge in South ruislip to say that I
am stepping down forth with and
triggering an immediate by-election I am
very sorry to leave my wonderful
constituency it has been a huge honor to
serve them as mayor and MP but I am
proud that after what is community
cumulatively sorry a 15-year stint I've
helped to deliver lots of things that
he's helped to deliver he continues it's
very sad to be leaving Parliament at
least for now but above all I am
bewildered and appalled that I can be
forced out anti-democratically by a
committed shared and managed by Harriet
Harman that's Labor's Harriet Harman
with such egregious bias
I mean
stunning former prime minister he stood
down as an MP he's triggered by-election